>> SALLY: Ich mache es jetzt.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt,
ob der Effekt klappt.
[Musik]
Oh!
Haha!
Ha!
Wow!
[Musik]
Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein Schmecksperiment.
Denn ich habe was entdeckt.
Auf Pinterest und auf Instagram
kursieren gerade Videos.
Und ich weiß nicht warum,
aber in meinem Such-Feed,
in diesem Feed Search,
da kommen immer Torten- und Kuchenrezepte.
Vielleicht, weil es mein Hobby ist
und es mein Interesse weckt.
Und da habe ich jetzt was gesehen,
eine Torte, die nennt sich Bolo Tsunami.
Die kommt anscheinend aus Portugal.
Und ich habe dann gegoogelt:
Was heißt denn "Bolo Tsunami"?
Es heißt Tsunami-Kuchen.
Ja.
Und ich verstehe zwar jetzt nicht...
Josh, warum heißt die Tsunami-Kuchen?
>> JOSH: Ja,
>> SALLY: Dieses Rezept.
>> JOSH: weil da dann die Schokolade
dann wie so ein Tsunami,
wie so eine Tsunami-Welle
>> SALLY: Ach! Weil es...
>> JOSH: über den Kuchen dann so drüberschwappt.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Denn es ist eine Torte,
die wird praktisch richtig schön geschichtet
und wird auch so verschenkt.
Und dann nimmst du diese Folie ab
und diese Schokoladenmasse, die da oben als Schicht war,
die fließt über die Torte.
Und es gibt halt Videos, die sind recht gut,
und Videos, die sind halt so voll der Fail.
Und es gibt halt noch kein so richtiges Rezept davon.
Und ich habe mir gedacht:
Warum machen wir das nicht einfach zum Caketrend 2020?
Wir probieren es heute.
Wir machen heute einen Tsunami-Kuchen.
Und jetzt macht es auch Sinn,
denn der Schokoladen-Tsunami fließt praktisch
– ah! –
über diese ganze Torte
und überdeckt alles.
Weil ein Tsunami
immer
wuhhh
alles...
Okay.
Ich habe es verstanden.
Ich fange jetzt zuerst mal an.
Ich rede mit dem Josh immer so viel Dialekt.
Ich fange jetzt zuerst einmal an
und werde einen Biskuit zubereiten,
einen Schokoladenbiskuit.
Das ist eigentlich ein Basisrezept.
Ich mache den Kuchen 20 cm groß,
gar nicht zu groß.
Sonst braucht ihr ja noch mehr Schokoladenmasse.
Und dann probieren wir es einfach,
ob es klappt oder nicht,
ob das Schmecksperiment gelingt oder eben nicht.
Für den Biskuit nehme ich
drei Eier,
– die sind bereits zimmerwarm –
75 Gramm Zucker und eine Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
60 Gramm Mehl
und 25 Gramm Kakao.
Ja.
Also wichtig beim Biskuit ist einfach,
Eier-Zucker-Masse richtig schaumig rühren
beziehungsweise cremig sogar, nicht nur schaumig.
Das heißt, die Eier kommen jetzt hierein.
Da kommen jetzt Salz, Zucker und Vanille dazu.
Und, wie gesagt, dann wird das Ganze
für etwa 10 bis 15 Minuten sogar
richtig cremig verrührt.
So könnt ihr auch das Backpulver weglassen
und der Biskuit wird einfach schön locker,
weil eben die Eiermasse schön locker gerührt wurde.
Jetzt kann ich hier das Mehl mit dem Kakao noch sieben.
Solltet ihr auf jeden Fall machen,
damit es einfach keine Klümpchen gibt.
Das Mehl ist zwar recht klümpchenfrei,
aber Kakao klumpt doch ganz gerne mal.
[Musik]
Und ganz vorsichtig unterheben.
Und dann den Schneebesen auch nicht an den Rand klopfen.
Denn dann klopft ihr die eingeschlagene Luft wieder raus.
Das wollen wir ja nicht.
Und jetzt habe ich hier
meinen Backring bereits auf 20 cm eingestellt.
Ich stelle den jetzt hier an den Rand.
Denn ich habe noch eine zweite Biskuitmasse angerührt.
Ich dachte mir, sicher ist sicher,
ich mache mal zwei.
Bei den Schmecksperimenten geht es zwar
nicht immer darum, dass es supergut gelingt,
aber ich meine, ich will ja, dass es gelingt
und nicht endet wie beim Angel Food Cake,
der einfach so gar nichts wurde.
Da muss ich übrigens
– den muss ich noch mal testen.
Den muss ich testen!
Ja.
Das kann ich so nicht belassen.
Und ich glaube, bei dem Kuchen hier
ist einfach die Schwierigkeit, diese Glasur so hinzukriegen,
dass es einmal schön fließt, nicht zu fest ist,
aber es muss ja dann auch die richtige Menge sein.
Also der Kuchen darf ja nicht ertränken,
aber es darf ja nicht zu wenig sein.
Ist schon schwierig.
Okay.
Also ich habe hier noch mal die gleiche Masse,
fülle die noch kurz hier ein
und dann streiche ich beide schön glatt
und dann wird es gleich schon gebacken.
[Musik]
Der Biskuit ist jetzt gebacken.
Richtig perfekt!
Den lasse ich kurz abkühlen,
aber kann schon mal die Füllung machen.
Da dachte ich, wäre es doch ganz cool,
der Boden ist ja ein Schokoboden
dann möchte ich noch Erdbeeren reinschichten
und dann hätte ich gerne eine helle Creme
und später diesen Tsunami,
diese Tsunami-Glasur dann auch wieder als Schokolade.
Also mache ich jetzt eine deutsche Buttercreme.
Dafür nehme ich
500 Gramm Milch,
eine Prise Salz,
90 Gramm Zucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
45 Gramm Stärke,
drei Eigelbe
und 320 Gramm weiche Butter.
Ich denke, so rein von meinem Gefühl her
dürfte die Menge zu viel sein.
Also wahrscheinlich ist davon die Hälfte ganz gut.
Aber ich mache jetzt lieber etwas mehr
und habe was übrig.
Ja.
Also deutsche Buttercreme.
Wie gesagt, die Butter soll weich sein.
Und jetzt nehmt ihr im Prinzip einfach nur einen Topf,
gebt die Stärke rein,
die Eigelbe.
Und das Eiweiß einfach aufbewahren,
einfrieren zum Beispiel
oder auch etwas anderes daraus zaubern.
Eiweiß brauchen wir heute nicht.
Dann Vanilleextrakt dazu,
damit es ein Vanillepudding wird.
Zucker und Salz.
Und jetzt mit der Milch aufgießen
und schön klümpchenfrei verrrühren.
Und dann die Masse als Pudding aufkochen lassen
hier auf dem Herd bei mittelhoher Hitze.
Dabei ständig rühren,
damit nichts anbrennt.
Jetzt wird der Pudding fest.
Er darf jetzt auch einmal aufkochen.
Und dann gieße ich ihn direkt in einen flachen Teller,
also mit ein bisschen Rand,
damit er einfach schneller abkühlt,
decke ihn an der Oberfläche mit Frischhaltefolie ab,
damit sich keine Haut bildet,
und lasse ihn komplett abkühlen.
Und in der Zeit können wir schon mal
die Tsunami-Glasur machen.
Da überlege ich mir jetzt mal was.
Ja. Da war es nämlich so,
da habe ich gefunden,
dass es oft mit Kondensmilch gemacht wird
– ich mache es ja mit Schokolade –
und mit saurer Sahne anscheinend.
Viele nehmen dann noch Milchpulver.
Das habe ich nicht.
Aber ich denke mir mal kurz was aus
und dann zeige ich euch die Zutaten.
[Musik]
Also für den Bolo Tsunami nehme ich
200 Gramm Sahne,
200 Gramm Zartbitterkuvertüre,
250 Gramm gezuckerte Kondensmilch,
200 Gramm saure Sahne,
250 Gramm Milch
und 15 Gramm Speisestärke.
Ja.
Anscheinend ist die gezuckerte Kondensmilch
ein wichtiger Bestandteil.
Ich denke, die gibt
dieser Glasur den Glanz.
Wie gesagt, dieses Milchpulver habe ich nicht.
Und ich habe so viele verschiedene Rezepte gefunden
und bei den meisten hat es einfach nicht geklappt.
Also dachte ich mir,
mach halt dein eigenes.
Ja.
Ich würde jetzt wie vorgehen?
Ich würde jetzt erst mal eine Ganache herstellen.
Also Sahne in den Topf und aufkochen lassen.
Ich habe mich in der Sekunde,
in der der Josh die Kameras umgestellt hat,
umentschieden.
Wir machen keine Ganache zuerst.
Denn sonst bräuchte ich ja zwei Töpfe.
Ich will aber nur einen Topf benutzen.
Ich gebe jetzt die Sahne
in den Topf
trotzdem,
aber ich gebe die Schokolade nicht rein.
Wartet.
Ja, so schnell geht es, Josh.
So schnell.
Ich habe mich mit dir unterhalten
und dann währenddessen
noch mein Rezept im Kopf umgeplant.
Denn die Stärke muss ja auch eingekocht werden.
Also Sahne und Milch,
Stärke rein,
kurz verrühren.
Ich weiß auch nicht irgendwie.
Ja.
Das Ganze jetzt aufkochen lassen.
Wenn man das Ganze hell machen will,
muss man natürlich die Menge...
Weil da lässt man ja praktisch die dunkle Schokolade weg
oder die Kuvertüre weg,
nimmt dann weiße Kuvertüre.
Aber da verändert sich die Menge.
Also das müsste ich dann noch mal ausprobieren.
Ich bin aber nicht so Weiße-Schokoladen-Fan.
Ist mir zu süß.
Also das lassen wir jetzt kochen,
damit die Stärke,
die Maisstärke,
einfach bindet
praktisch ähnlich wie beim Pudding gerade eben.
Ich frage mich nur, was die saure Sahne da dann soll.
Die verstehe ich nicht so ganz.
Vielleicht, um einfach den Geschmack so ein bisschen
von dem Süßen wegzunehmen,
dass es einfach so eine leichte Säure mit drin hat.
So.
Das kocht jetzt.
Dann
gebe ich die gezuckerte Kondensmilch dazu.
So.
Dann schalte ich jetzt den Herd aus.
Denn
die Gefahr,
dass die Kondensmilch jetzt am Topfboden festbrennt,
ist zu hoch.
Okay.
Jetzt die Kuvertüre rein in kleinen Stückchen.
Ihr könnt sie auch fein hacken vorher oder reiben.
Dann geht es noch schneller.
Aber normalerweise müsste ja die Restwärme
jetzt eigentlich schon ausreichen.
Und jetzt einfach rühren.
Einfach rühren.
Einfach, einfach, einfach rühren.
Wer bin ich?
>> JOSH: Dorie?
>> SALLY: Ja!
Ich bin Dorie.
Ich kann auch Walisch.
>> JOSH: Komm! Komm! Mach weiter!
>> SALLY: Iichh maachhee heeutee
eeinn Schmeecksspeeriimeentt.
Hast du es verstanden?
>> JOSH: Nee.
Ich kann leider kein Walisch.
>> SALLY: Du kannst kein Walisch?
>> JOSH: Nee, das kann ich nicht.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Ich kann Walisch, ich kann Löffelsprache,
Türkisch, Englisch und Deutsch
et un peu français.
>> JOSH: In jeder Sprache finde ich, hörst du dich gut an.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Die Schokolade hat sich gelöst.
Und jetzt kommt hier noch die saure Sahne dazu.
Ich behaupte jetzt einfach mal,
sie dient dem Geschmack.
Und ich hoffe, sie versaut mir jetzt nicht
die komplette Creme.
Okay.
Sieht nicht schlecht aus.
Sollen wir den Geschmackstest machen?
>> JOSH: Ja.
Oh, zwei große Löffel heute?
>> SALLY: Heute gibt es zwei große Löffel.
Mmh!
Ich muss schon sagen,
>> JOSH: Hui!
>> SALLY: schmeckt gut.
Süß,
>> JOSH: Sehr lecker!
>> SALLY: aber gut.
Ich glaube, später mit den Erdbeeren und so
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: wird das gut kommen.
Ich möchte jetzt einfach sicherheitshalber
die Masse noch sieben,
damit ich einfach keine Klümpchen habe
Also, wenn dieser Tsunami Cake nicht klappt, Josh,
>> JOSH: Ja?
>> SALLY: dann machen wir einfach ein Löffeldessert daraus.
Dann essen wir alle mit dem Löffel daraus,
tunken die Erdbeeren ein und fertig.
>> JOSH: Mir kam gerade so ein Gedanke.
Du könntest auch einen neuen Versuch starten
und dann
Nougat nehmen.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Wow!
Nougat-Tsunami!
Das ist natürlich...
Das ist richtig gut,
Nougat-Tsunami.
Das lasse ich jetzt komplett abkühlen.
Denn ich muss ja wissen,
wie die Konsistenz ist,
– ich finde sie fast schon zu dick –
wie die Konsistenz ist, wenn die Masse abkühlt.
Dann muss sie ja auch fließen,
aber halt nicht zu dünn werden.
Wir werden sehen.
Kann sein, dass ich vielleicht noch mal Sahne
oder Milch oder so zufüge.
Aber jetzt warten wir einfach ab.
Ich decke es ab.
Und wir können jetzt eigentlich schon,
weil der Biskuit abgekühlt ist und
der Vanillepudding auch,
können wir eigentlich schon die Torte füllen.
Und das kommt jetzt...
Da kommt noch Frischhaltefolie darüber.
Jetzt machen wir einfach den Schwabentrick
und legen das jetzt hier so darauf.
So.
Folie gespart.
[Musik]
Hat man das gesehen?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Die weiche Butter kommt jetzt in die Schüssel
und wird schaumig gerührt.
Also es geht jetzt einfach mit der Buttercreme weiter.
Und die rührt ihr wirklich richtig weißcremig.
Jetzt sieht sie ja noch relativ gelb aus,
aber gleich
wird sie weißcremig.
Aber die Maschine schalte ich gleich an.
Den Pudding könnt ihr jetzt entweder so lassen
und einfach nur kurz verrühren
oder ihr streicht ihn durch ein Sieb,
damit einfach auch hier die Klümpchen verschwinden.
So mache ich das jetzt kurz.
Ich nehme einfach hier das fleißige Lieschen.
Ihr könnt aber auch ein ganz normales Haarsieb nehmen
so, wie ich vorhin.
Nur habe ich hier den Vorteil,
dass ich einfach nicht mit dem Teigschaber schaben muss
oder mit einem Schneebesen,
sondern das einfach schön durchrühren kann.
[Musik]
Und jetzt gebt ihr den Pudding einfach
esslöffelweise zur Buttercreme dazu
und schlagt alles schön cremig.
[Musik]
Ich mache nicht den DJ heute.
Okay.
Also
zuerst kurz
hier den Biskuit rauslösen.
Ich habe den Biskuit einfach jetzt komplett abkühlen lassen
und dann noch mal ganz kurz
mit dem Blech in den Kühlschrank gestellt.
So lässt er sich gleich besser schneiden.
Wow!
Die Tortenböden schneide ich jetzt noch durch.
Das geht mit einer Tortensäge echt ganz gut
und vor allem auch gleichmäßig.
So.
Dann drehe ich es jetzt noch einmal um
und kann die Backfolie lösen.
Ta-taa!
Und jetzt geht es schon an das Schichten der Torte.
Also ich habe hier einfach einen Tortenretter.
Ich nehme den.
Der sieht besser aus.
Und jetzt kommt hier drumherum eine Folie.
Denn die Torte wird dann mit der Folie,
mit der Tortenfolie sozusagen verschenkt und angerichtet.
Dann hat man diese schönen Schichten, die man sieht.
Und dann nimmt man die Folie weg
und hat eben diesen tollen Effekt.
Okay.
Ich habe jetzt hier eine extrahohe.
Denn es soll eine hohe Torte werden.
Und die darf jetzt halt auch nicht zu dünn sein.
Ich habe da jetzt einfach so eine extra Folie bestellt.
Ich mache sie, glaube ich, vielleicht sogar doppelt.
Habe ich meine Schere irgendwohin?
Ah, ja.
Ich glaube, von dir brauche ich gleich, Josh,
ein bisschen Klebeband.
>> JOSH: Ja, kriegst du.
>> SALLY: Ja.
So sieht es gut aus.
Es würde sogar ohne halten.
Mh.
Ich glaube, ein bisschen.
Ah, wobei, ich mache später eine Schleife darum.
Ich glaube, ich nehme es.
Nee, ich nehme keines.
Denn...
Doch. Ich nehme doch.
Es ist ein Schmecksperiment!
Ich kann mich noch umentscheiden.
Und das kann ich ja später noch wegnehmen
für die Optik.
Aber mir ist das, glaube ich, jetzt echt gerade zu heikel.
Und, weil ich Stabilität brauche,
setze ich jetzt noch
den Ring außenrum.
Den nehme ich dann natürlich weg,
bevor wir den Effekt machen.
Aber die Creme ist ja jetzt noch sehr dünn,
also auch jetzt gerade diese Buttercreme.
Und die wird ja im Kühlschrank fest.
Vom Stand, denke ich, kriegen wir das gut hin.
Ich habe jetzt hier noch Erdbeeren.
Die schichte ich jetzt noch rein.
Und zwar entferne ich das Grün.
Ich nehme jetzt leider
auch ein bisschen was von der Erdbeere weg.
Aber das könnt ihr ja einfach naschen,
den Part hier.
Josh, wir machen einfach gleich Smoothies.
>> JOSH: Ja. Das klingt gut.
>> SALLY: Und dann nehme ich die Erdbeere
und halbiere sie und setze sie jetzt
mit der Schnittkante nach außen an die Folie,
damit man die später von außen auch gut sieht.
[Musik]
Und jetzt einfach die Mitte
mit den restlichen Erdbeeren auslegen.
Und die braucht ihr jetzt nicht halbieren,
sondern könnt sie wirklich schön im Ganzen reinlegen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt habe ich hier die Vanillecreme.
Und die fülle ich jetzt in einen Spritzbeutel.
So ist das Füllen etwas einfacher.
Und ihr müsst natürlich darauf achten,
dass ihr die Torte sauber befüllt.
Denn man wird ja von außen die einzelnen Schichten sehen.
Daher ist der Spritzbeutel super geeignet,
damit ihr eine schöne gerade Fläche habt.
Huch!
Und dann jetzt erst mal im Inneren,
also die ganzen Erdbeerlücken erst mal bedecken
und dann die Creme schön gerade abschließen lassen.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt der zweite Tortenboden darauf.
Und da achte ich jetzt darauf,
dass keine Brösel an der Folie sind.
Dann wieder eine Schicht Creme.
Wie war das vorhin?
"Die Creme wird auf jeden Fall für zwei Torten ausreichen."
Okay, sie reicht doch nur für eine.
>> JOSH: Ja.
Kann das sein,
dass die Torte auch ein Kalorien-Tsunami wird?
>> SALLY: Das wird auch ein Kalorien-Tsunami.
Aber,
als ich heute Morgen in unserer Besprechung gesagt habe,
ich mache hier Tsunami-Cake,
vielleicht auch zwei,
haben sich alle gefreut.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und der Marcel hat gesagt:
"Oh, wie schade!
Dann müssen wir das ja alles aufessen."
Und ich war so: "Ja."
Sally, The Feeder,
macht alle in Waghäusel und um Waghäusel herum dick.
[Musik]
Und dann werde ich die Torte jetzt erst mal kühlstellen,
damit die Buttercreme fest wird.
Und wir kontrollieren gleich mal die Tsunami-Masse.
Wie sich das anhört!
Die Tsunami-Masse.
Denn die muss ja im gekühlten Zustand sogar,
also im kühlschrankkalten Zustand muss die ja
diese Konsistenz haben, die ich will.
Also das kommt jetzt hier in den Kühlschrank.
Ein bisschen Buttercreme habe ich übrig.
Aber...
Ach, komm. Die hauen wir auch noch drauf, oder?
Ich meine, ja, das bisschen, das lohnt sich jetzt auch nicht,
das noch irgendwie aufzuheben.
Die 40 Gramm Butter
nehmen wir jetzt auch noch mit.
[Musik]
Ich weiß ja noch nicht so ganz, ob das gleich klappt
beim ersten Mal.
Deswegen fülle ich jetzt noch eine Torte.
Sicher ist sicher.
Heute darf nichts schiefgehen!
Ich setze hier jetzt auch gleich den Ring wieder außenrum.
Aber ich wollte die Erdbeeren jetzt mal so reinsetzen.
So sieht man es auch schön von außen.
[Musik]
Okay.
Ich bin gespannt.
Also
für mein Empfinden
ist das zu dick.
Für mein Empfinden ist es genau so dick
wie bei den anderen, die das eben auch so gemacht haben,
so dickflüssig.
Nee.
Nee, nee.
Seht ihr? Das fließt gar nicht.
Mhm.
Okay.
Josh, wir machen eine Abstimmung.
Gießen wir Sahne rein oder Milch?
Okay, Sahne.
>> JOSH: Ich...
>> SALLY: Okay. Nee, weil...
>> JOSH: Beides gut.
>> SALLY: Sahne?
Weil Kondensmilch will ich jetzt nicht noch mehr.
Das wäre mir dann schon zu süß.
Milch?
>> JOSH: Sahne?
>> SALLY: Sahne?
Ich würde sagen, Sahne.
Weil
man gönnt sich ja sonst nichts!
Ich hole kurz Sahne.
Kann schon sein.
Okay. Ich hoffe, das klappt jetzt einfach so.
Weil ich will es jetzt halt nicht mehr erwärmen.
Ich meine, ich habe es jetzt gerade so schön abgekühlt
und ich habe jetzt den letzten Schritt sozusagen.
Ich habe jetzt hier mal 200.
Mal gucken, wie viel ich nehme.
Wir machen mal langsam.
Das sieht besser aus.
Wie könnte ich das testen?
[Musik]
Ich könnte...
Ich weiß.
Josh, das wird jetzt voll das Experiment.
Ist es blöd, weißt du, wenn ich das praktisch...
Ich muss was haben, wo ich dann den Ring so
wegziehen kann und dann fließt es da runter,
so darüber.
Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt gerade Sinn macht,
was ich mache.
Aber
ich will zumindest mal sehen,
ob es fließt.
Weil das wäre ja der Ring.
Zumindest will ich sehen, wie es fließt.
Du siehst es auch schon kommen,
dass das Ding einfach runter-
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: -fällt?
Okay, es war blöd.
Eine Hand hätte halten sollen.
Gleichgewichtsübung.
Aber ich glaube, jetzt passt es wirklich.
Und jetzt kommt der magische Moment
und es wäre dieses...
Oh!
Haha!
Ha!
Wow!
Jetzt ist aber noch
die Frage mit der Höhe und der Menge.
Weil
du darfst nicht zu wenig haben,
damit es wirklich am kompletten Kuchen runterfließt.
Du darfst aber auch nicht zu viel haben,
weil sonst ertränkt es ja auch.
Gibt es da nicht bestimmt eine Formel?
Da kann man doch bestimmt eine Formel aufstellen.
So: Die Torte ist so und so viel hoch,
also fülle...
Ein Drittel?
Okay.
Ja. Ja, wir machen das so.
Also ich finde, das war jetzt optimistisch.
Und ich finde, die Konsistenz
– guckt mal,
so vom Löffel runter.
Es fließt nicht vom Löffel,
es soll aber auch nicht.
Denn, wenn sich das löst, fließt es darüber.
Klappt es?
>> JOSH: Toi, toi, toi!
>> SALLY: Toi, toi, toi!
Puh!
Das...
Ich bin sehr optimistisch.
Die ist so 8 cm hoch.
Ja, das...
Ich fülle es jetzt nach Augenmaß.
Vielleicht kann ich auch schon den Ring abnehmen.
Dann sehe ich es.
Weil jetzt ist die Torte fest.
Ja, die sieht schon nice aus.
Sie hätte für meinen Geschmack
ein bisschen höher sein dürfen.
Gell?
Hätte schon noch der eine Boden...
Aber nehmen wir es so?
Sonst müsste ich jetzt noch mal backen.
Die Handbewegung hättet ihr jetzt sehen müssen.
Okay.
[Musik]
Ich mache es jetzt.
Ungefähr ein Drittel.
Ich meine, wenn hier jetzt heute
alles mit diesem Augenmaß wieder passt,
dann
möchte ich mich bitte als offizielle Augenmaßexpertin
eintragen lassen.
Denn ich nehme jetzt auch noch das.
Das war ja alles sauber.
Oh, es hat sich ein Vakuum gebildet.
Das sah aus wie Charlie Chaplins Hut
so von der Form her.
>> JOSH: Junge, Junge.
Weißt du, was ich fast glaube?
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> JOSH: Dass das echt ein bisschen zu wenig ist.
>> SALLY: Zu wenig?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: O Gott! Ich habe auch die Befürchtung.
Das ist nicht ein Drittel.
[Musik]
Das heißt für mich,
ich muss jetzt noch mal was machen.
Aber ich denke schon, das müsste ein Drittel auf jeden Fall.
Das reicht niemals!
Okay.
Ich hoffe, das wirkt sich jetzt nicht auf die Torte,
also auf das aus.
Aber es war ja schon im Kühlschrank kalt.
Ich werde gleich...
Ich mache jetzt noch mal die Menge.
Und dann sehen wir gleich,
ob es klappt.
Ich mache jetzt einfach die doppelte Menge noch mal.
Denn ich habe ja noch die andere Torte,
die Sicherheitstorte.
Drei Stunden später
hat sie noch einmal die Masse gemacht.
Und die geheime Geheimformel sagt,
wir machen ein Drittel.
Wann ist es ein Drittel?
O Mannomannomann!
Ich hoffe, das verbindet sich jetzt halt.
Weil...
Noch ein bisschen, Josh?
>> JOSH: Schon.
>> SALLY: Schon?
Schaufel drauf, schaufel drauf!
Puh!
Also man sieht halt, die andere, die untere
hat sich schon ein bisschen noch mal gefestigt
im Kühlschrank.
Man sieht einen leichten Farbverlauf.
Aber es wäre doch nicht schlimm, oder?
>> JOSH: Ich glaube nicht.
>> SALLY: Meinst du das reicht?
Ich denke schon.
Weil hier jetzt,
wenn ich jetzt so überlege,
so...
Ja.
Und in vielen Videos war es dann noch so,
dass dann obendrauf noch Schokostreusel waren.
Es sah bei manchen gut aus, bei manchen nicht.
Aber ich mache es jetzt.
Und dann machen wir jetzt gleich eine Schleife darum,
damit ich die unschönen
Klebestreifen wegnehmen kann.
Das ist jetzt auch noch mal eine Kunst für sich.
O Gott!
Uff!
Hast du es auch schon fallen sehen?
>> JOSH: Beinahe.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, der Ring verformt sich
und die Schokolade läuft so
>> SALLY: Wow!
>> JOSH: im Ring drin runter.
>> SALLY: Im linken Ring drin. Ja.
>> JOSH: Im linken Ring.
>> SALLY: Im Lingling.
Okay, wir lassen es jetzt noch mal so.
Und dann gucken wir gleich, ob es klappt.
Und hier, muss ich jetzt echt sagen,
zahlt sich der Tortenständer,
also der
Cake Stand, Tortenständer,
Tortenservierplatte
mit Fuß
zahlt sich echt aus.
Denn dieser Rand wird verhindern,
dass die Schokolade dann überläuft.
So die Theorie.
>> JOSH: Sie läuft über den Rand hinaus.
>> SALLY: Das werden wir sehen.
Komm. Wir machen noch ein Abschlusserinnerungsfoto.
[Musik]
Josh, ich habe doch gesagt,
ich habe eine Box mit Geschenkbändern.
Huch!
Ta-daa!
So. Welche Farbe?
Oh, das sieht fein aus!
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Habe ich ja gesagt, so Gold
oder irgendwas mit Rot.
Die zusammen wären gut!
>> SALLY: Das wäre Sally-Pink, das wäre zu...
Ich finde das hier gut.
>> SAMIRA: Aber die beiden zusammen
wären doch noch schöner.
>> SALLY: Nee, das Band nehmen wir nicht.
Wir nehmen nur
so ein schönes.
[Musik]
Dann der Trick, das so nach außen biegen.
Oh! Dann schneide ich ja voll viel weg.
Dann hätte ich es gar nicht so lang machen müssen.
Das wollen wir auch nicht.
Der Schwabe in mir sagt: "Mach es noch mal auf."
Der andere Schwabe, der Badener sagt:
"Ach, lass es doch. Die Zeit ist wertvoller."
Ich höre jetzt auf den Badener.
Okay.
Ich versuche das jetzt wegzunehmen,
ohne dass es aufgeht.
Das ist schon mal Hürde Nummer eins.
Ach, das hintere lasse ich dran.
Das sieht keiner.
So.
Bolo Tsunami.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt,
ob der Effekt klappt.
Wenn ich diese Folie hochhebe
und wegnehme,
muss die Schokoladensoße
komplett über die Torte fließen
und dabei noch schön aussehen
und schmecken.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist es so weit.
Ich schaue jetzt, ob der Bolo Tsunami Cake funktioniert.
Okay.
Die Erdbeeren stehen.
[Musik]
Lauf!
Weißt du, was wir bei dem ein Drittel nicht berechnet haben?
Was auf der Folie über bleibt.
Komm! Lauf weiter!
Komm, lauf weiter!
Nein!
Ein bisschen bräuchte ich noch hier.
Wie sieht es bei euch vorne aus?
>> JOSH: Ziemlich gut eigentlich.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich glaube, der läuft jetzt noch.
So ein bisschen so zack, zack.
Komm, der läuft noch runter.
Doch, der läuft noch. Ich sehe es.
Okay.
Also eigentlich...
Also ich muss schon sagen...
Also so
dafür, dass es alles so nach Augenmaß war
und alles so in meinem Kopf berechnet
und zum ersten Mal
und so direkt vor der Kamera getestet,
muss ich schon sagen,
dass dieses Schmecksperiment geglückt ist.
Jetzt muss er nur noch schmecken.
Aber da mache ich mir keine Sorgen.
Aber ich würde sagen,
Bolo Tsunami Cake,
check.
Jetzt sieht es zwar aus wie ein Unfall,
aber der Effekt war cool.
Ich glaube, es kommt auf den Effekt an.
Ich werde dann gleich so einen Ticken mehr dazu machen
für den zweiten, den ich ja auch vorbereitet habe.
Und dann läuft es auf einmal so rüber.
Ja.
Aber ich glaube, so geschmacklich
müsste er schon Bombe sein!
Dim-dim, dim-dim, dim-dim.
Ups!
Ja, der Bahti hätte eigentlich den Kuchen probieren sollen.
Jetzt hat er ihn aufgrund seiner Telefoniererei verpasst!
Tja, Bahti,
Bolo Tsunami!
Muss ich halt essen.
Bahti...
Komm, Bahti.
Hi, Ela!
Oh! Kaum gibt es Schokolade,
guck mal, wer am Fenster klopft!
Guck mal.
>> JOSH: Dann mache ich mal auf.
>> SALLY: O Mann!
>> BAHTIYAR: Woah!
>> SAMIRA: Mama, hat es geklappt?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> BAHTIYAR: Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich hingucken soll!
>> SALLY: Also jetzt sieht es aus wie ein Unfall.
Aber hast du den Effekt gesehen?
>> BAHTIYAR: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hallo, ihr zwei! Kommt!
>> BAHTIYAR: Kommt, wir probieren alle zusammen.
>> SALLY: Die Riesenaugen!
>> SAMIRA: Oh!
>> SALLY: Das muss ich leider kurz umlegen.
>> ELA: Njam, njam!
>> SALLY: Kommt, probiert mal alle!
Bahti auch.
Ela auch.
Hier ist noch eine frische.
>> SAMIRA: Ich nehme auf jeden Fall eine Erdbeere.
>> SALLY: Ihr müsst es mit der Creme probieren.
>> SAMIRA: Die Creme.
>> SALLY: Die Schokocreme.
>> SAMIRA: Die andere Creme.
>> SALLY: Also ich finde es schon hammerlecker!
Muss man mal testen!
>> SAMIRA: Jetzt habe ich alles.
Aber ich habe die Gabel falsch rum.
>> SALLY: Egal.
Komm.
Bahti, komm auch.
>> ELA: Ich nehme die Creme,
dann noch die andere Creme.
>> SALLY: Also geschmacklich ist es echt perfekt lecker!
Vor allem, weil die Schokocreme noch so weich ist.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> BAHTIYAR: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> BAHTIYAR: Super!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Also, wenn mir jemand so die Torte präsentieren würde,
würde ich denken: "Was war das für ein Unfall?!"
Aber
vorher so mit der Schicht schon ziemlich cool.
Also
Schmecksperiment geglückt?
>> BAHTIYAR: Perfekt!
>> SALLY: Sehr gut!
Und, wie gesagt, die Folie braucht ihr halt auf jeden Fall
eben für den Effekt.
Klar würde es auch gehen,
wenn man einfach nur einen Tortenring nimmt,
aber ich finde, dann geht einfach der Effekt verloren.
Denn dann hat man im Prinzip
einfach nur noch diese Schokosuppe darüber.
Und vorher sieht man,
dass es eben eine perfekte geschichtete Torte ist
mit einem flüssigen Schokoladenüberzug.
Juhu, Schmecksperiment geglückt!
Also probiert es gerne mal aus.
Falls ihr weitere Ideen habt für diese Videoreihe,
dann schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Und ich hoffe, euch gefällt das Video.
Ihr könnt ja mal schreiben.
Findet ihr, dieser Bolo Tsunami Cake
könnte der Caketrend 2020 werden?
Ja oder nein?
Findet ihr es cool oder sagt ihr so:
"Nee, danach sieht er einfach furchtbar aus"?
>> ELA: Nein.
>> SAMIRA: Es gibt bessere.
>> SALLY: Also geschmacklich finde ich es Hammer!
Also mega!
>> BAHTIYAR: Für mich ganz klar Trend.
>> SALLY: Megatrend.
Josh?
Trend.
Samira?
Trend. Okay.
Samira, kleine Samira sagt?
Auch?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Musst nicht. Du kannst auch sagen Nö.
>> SALLY: Ela, was sagst du?
>> SAMIRA: Also...
>> ELA: Mama, darf ich dir was ins Ohr flüstern?
>> SALLY: Ins Ohr flüstern? Ja, flüster.
>> ELA: Also schreib mal, sag mal:
"Wer einen perfekten Namen hat für den Kuchen..."
>> SALLY: Was?
>> ELA: "Wer einen perfekten Namen hat für diesen Kuchen,
der schreibt es in die Kommentare."
>> SALLY: Ja, dann ist okay.
Also Ela sagt:
"Wenn ihr einen perfekten Namen habt für diesen Kuchen,
dann schreibt es in die Kommentare."
O Mann, du YouTuber-Kind!
Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
>> BAHTIYAR: Tschau!
>> SAMIRA: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Bist du etwa Influencer?
>> ELA: Nein!
>> SALLY: Nein?
>> SAMIRA: Nein!
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> SAMIRA: Auf gar keinen Fall!
>> SALLY: Was?
>> ELA: Auf gar keinen Fall!
>> BAHTIYAR: Ela, sollen wir uns mit dem Kuchen verdrücken?
Komm, wir zwei nehmen mal den Kuchen mit.
>> SALLY: Oh, oh!
Tschüss!
>> BAHTIYAR: Tschau!
>> SAMIRA: Also ich will noch was zum Kuchen sagen.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> SAMIRA: Von außen
sieht...
Also von außen ist er so ein bisschen mh.
Aber von innen und auch der Geschmack ist halt richtig lecker!
>> SALLY: Würde ich auch sagen.
Und die Folie, die müsst ihr auch auskratzen!
Die komplette Schokolade leer essen!
Tschüss!
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Das ist der Foodtrend 2020!
Also wirklich ein absolutes Hammerding!
Das Ding wird in die Annalen eingehen
und zwar nicht
– und zwar in Sturmis Annalen.
So.
Ein ganz krasses Ding!
So was hat man noch nie gesehen!
Es ist wirklich,
es ist ein absoluter Trend!
Ich glaube, das wird jetzt morgen
überall in den Zeitungen stehen
und überall in allen TV- und Quizshows nachgemacht.
Okay.
Wie geht das jetzt, Schatz?
Machen wir was?
>> SALLY: Jaa!
>> MURAT: Soll ich das Ding jetzt hochheben?
>> SALLY: Nein!
>> MURAT: Wie heißt das? Tsunami?
>> SALLY: Bolo Tsunami!
>> MURAT: Bolo Tsunami heißt das.
Und zwar Bolognese und Tsunami gleichzeitig.
Das wird den Sturm extrem freuen!
Und das Ding...
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Weißt du, was auch
das Besondere an diesem Kuchen ist?
Ihr kennt doch diesen Spuckschutz, was du hast.
Das ist auch ein Spuckschutz.
Und zwar ist es sozusagen eine Corona-Torte.
Genau.
Da ist das Ding.
Kennt jeder Plexiglas heutzutage?
Kennt jeder, oder?
So vor dem Gesicht.
Und hier ist es an der Torte.
Jetzt das Ding einfach hochheben?
>> SALLY: Ja, ich mache das.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Meine Frau macht das jetzt.
Wirklich!
Ihr seht das morgen in jeder Zeitschrift,
in jeder Fernsehsendung.
Los!
>> SALLY: Also wir haben jetzt diesmal
ein bisschen mehr als ein Drittel drin.
Einfach, dass es wirklich auf einen Schlag...
Was ich noch machen will, ist,
– das habe ich vorhin echt vergessen.
Gut, dass wir noch ein Ende machen,
und gut, dass ich noch eine Torte habe.
Denn ich nominiere jemanden.
Ich nominiere gleich drei Personen,
um diese Bolo Tsunami Torte, den Caketrend 2020,
nachzumachen.
Platz Numero eins: Sturmi
>> MURAT: Sturmwaffel!
Platz Numero zwei: Malwanne
Und Platz Nummer drei:
>> SALLY & MURAT: Kelly MissesVlog
>> MURAT: Genau.
Genau.
Ihr drei, ihr müsst diese Torte machen.
Die heißt Bolo Tsunami.
>> SALLY: Gleichzeitig, zusammen, nacheinander.
Mir egal. Aber ihr seid jetzt nominiert.
>> MURAT: Am coolsten wäre es, wenn ihr es alle drei macht
und dann die Torte so hinstellt.
Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, bei wem es funktioniert.
Genau.
>> SALLY: Also
>> MURAT: Also, ihr drei, los!
>> SALLY: ich weiß, dass Malwanne und Kelly
gut backen können.
>> MURAT: Hä?!
Sturmi auch!
>> SALLY: Aber Sturmi kann es noch besser.
>> MURAT: Der hat neulich ein Ding, einen Hundekuchen gemacht.
>> SALLY: Der Sturmi kann es besser.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Also Bolo Tsunami.
>> SALLY: Okay. Komm.
Ich mache das.
Ich mache...
Murat, Schatz, ich will dich jetzt nicht Ding machen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich will dich nicht kränken.
>> SALLY: Aber ich mache gerade eine Handyaufnahme
und eine von da
und ich will nicht die haarigen Arme drin.
>> MURAT: Was hast du gegen meine haarigen Arme?
>> SALLY: Nichts.
>> MURAT: Was soll das?!
Das ist ein Schutz!
Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Ich hoffe, diesmal wird es noch schöner als vorhin. Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay. Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Bolo Tsunami!
Sturmi, Kelly, Malwanne, los!
Jetzt bin ich gespannt!
Kriegt ihr das hin?
Also ihr müsst hier oben und dann praktisch...
[Musik]
Oh! Diesmal war es etwas zu viel!
>> MURAT: O mein Gott! Das war ein richtiger Tsunami!
>> SALLY: Puh!
>> MURAT: Warte! Kann ich mich darunterlegen und...
Okay, geht nicht.
>> SALLY: Herzlich willkommen!
Das ist ein
>> MURAT: Bolo Tsunami!
>> SALLY: Das ist ein Schokobrunnen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Die richtige Menge herauszufinden,
ist etwas schwierig, aber ich finde,
>> MURAT: Boah, das ist mal geil! Boah!
>> SALLY: vorhin war es schon perfekt und superschön.
>> MURAT: Boah, ist das...
>> SALLY: Komm, ich schneide sie dir jetzt an.
Dann musst du sie jetzt auch noch probieren.
Komm!
Komm, das machen wir jetzt noch.
Die Zeit...
>> MURAT: Ich hole mal kurz einen Löffel.
Kann ich jetzt?
>> SALLY: Mir ist nur beim zweiten Schwung die Milch,
weil ich sie nicht im Kupfertopf gemacht habe,
unten angebrannt.
Deswegen schmeckt es so rauchig.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und Samira so: "Mama, ist da Kaffee drin?"
Und ich: "Nee, nee, Schatz.
Das ist der Geschmack von der Torte."
Ja, es schmeckt so leicht rauchig.
>> MURAT: Boah, ist das schokoladig!
Was ist da drin?
>> SALLY: Schokolade.
>> MURAT: Mmh! Ich wusste es.
>> SALLY: O Gott im Himmel!
>> MURAT: He, mal ohne Witz.
Was ist das? Ist das Pudding?
>> SALLY: Ja, so eine Art flüssigerer Pudding mit
schwarzer...
Du, mit dem?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß, warum er das hat.
Weil er das Besteck nicht findet,
weil wir es umgeräumt haben. Gell?
>> MURAT: Hm.
Hammer!
Wahnsinn!
So, Kelly und Malwanne
und Sturmi, jetzt könnt ihr euch mal schön batteln.
Foodtrend 2020!
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Schmeckt schon gut.
>> SALLY: Und ich finde, die Erdbeeren, die müssen sein.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Hammer!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Echt cool!
Wie gesagt,
auch
Spuckschutz-Torte genannt.
Mmh!
Boah!
Hammer!
Hammer! Wirklich!
Mmh!
Nachmachen!
Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Leckerschmecker!
>> MURAT: Trend 2020!
>> SALLY: Vielleicht
stellt ihr unter eure Tortenplatte noch ein Blech.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Vielleicht.
>> MURAT: Genau. Oder eine Regentonne.
>> SALLY: Oder eine Regentonne.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oder einen Topf.
Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Ich hole mal kurz den Kärcher.
SC 4, bitte.
>> SALLY: Hol den Marcel.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Der schleckt alles weg.